what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome MTR
[Music]
meet the man the myth the legend uh-oh
mediocre tutorials and reviews half a
million YouTube subscribers oh you gonna
pick me up like that girl the leading
reaction channel in the manosphere this
man gets more views than I do on my own
video
shout out to everybody the alpha male
yeah listen listen we got to give the
people what they want we gotta give them
the content Pearl again again can we
talk about that real quick yeah let's
talk about it so I was gonna say this is
gonna be the first time that I'm getting
an interview by somebody so actually
technically be the second time because
we are now redoing this podcast yeah
yeah we came in we came in yesterday
um and I interviewed you about your life
and all this stuff that the footage the
video didn't save yeah so now we're back
but we're just gonna do a better podcast
listen we're gonna it's gonna be a lot
better A lot more things we're gonna
talk about we gotta talk about some hot
button issues let's go in there you have
the audio right let me know in the
comments maybe we'll release the audio
from day one yeah yeah no maybe we
should yeah
[Applause]
yeah I'm up to my patreon oh you got
patreon now maybe I will say pearl we
gotta talk about that as well actually a
quick quick question you can yeah you
can ask me any questions okay any
question any question very good because
I will okay so I guess knowing so we've
had discussions regarding kind of the
business that you've been building on
the back end of everything that you're
doing with just pearly things
I know you must see the comments that
are saying things like you're going out
you're being a great businesswoman in
fact maybe even a boss chick like how do
you settle that with being you know 26
years old and kind of dating right like
like how do you I didn't mean to
answer man what you do
oh [__] I don't know I've always tried
to ounce I really wanted to just work
for somebody but honestly so many people
overlooked a Golden Goose
I've contacted so many people and
conservative media I just wanted to work
for someone yeah oh really I just got
elected as a hobby like it's fun to me
yeah do you know some people look at
stuff as a job and for the money I just
kind of look at stuff as like this is
fun I just like doing it what an awesome
job to just talk to people about where
they are at in life yeah and just dispel
the [__] yeah and I'm just a big I'm
just a big accountability person you
know if one day I die with my cats
because of my YouTube channel that'll be
my own damn fault that'll be my own damn
fault well at one side of the coin you
know you're doing you know some things
that people might say are lying to the
Modern Woman ideology but you know
you're building something and you said
are you good at it obviously you're
super talented at it which is kind of
sort of a shots fired to all the other
content creators I've been trying [__]
like this for a long amount of time but
but you're talented also in marrying
that like with the things that you're
doing such as the wife school right so
so but you're trying right like you know
what I'm so talented that I figured out
how to make it my job to get better at
being a wife for my husband boom mic
drop who else figured that out live
where they can all watch
clean crazy two birds one stone baby you
guys can pull that off Hey listen listen
listen listen I can't lie if there's not
a little bit within me that I'm just
like you know I I know I do the content
I know why uh how how important it is
for young men to hear the things that
we're doing especially young women as
well right so they can hear the
ideologies of accountability rights
things that they may not have ever
thought about within their life but at
the same Junction I would be remiss not
to say that there's also not a benefit
of getting your name out into places
from a status symbol you know so that
people can find you that could be more
in line with your brand the thing is is
that you'll be much it'll be much more
easy for you to be outright with your
ideologies than behind closed doors and
then dating men who are not aligned to
that particular ideology same thing for
me like I feel like like people ask me
like yo how's dating now that you do
content and I'm like
it's easier because now there's no rigor
remote there's no [__] status oh my
God we love status especially for a guy
guys don't care about status for me
they're like oh she has a YouTube
channel that's nice don't care no but
they might care about how much money
that you make
the map you think I thought men don't
care about your money you think men do
care
I do think that there are a subset of
men that get insecure when the lady in
their life they don't feel as though
that they can provide for them because
she will make she makes significantly
more money I do think that that does
talk uh Target some men as they're
dating so what I found is that if you
treat him like he's the man he don't
care I'm with you and so like the
problem is the girls will act like
they're better than everyone I don't
think I'm better how okay how am I gonna
be better than a guy let's just say
let's not think of a normal job like
like a fireman man's putting out fires
or police officers I'm not better than
them well I just talk for a living but
there seems to be something in like the
Modern Woman ideology that aligns kind
of how much money that you make to how
you treat people around you and
especially from a dating perspective as
well so I think that the idea of that in
our culture
men just don't want to sign up for that
you know that's what I say like dudes
would much rather date the beautiful
woman that's at you know Starbucks
versus the walking boss be lawyer
partner at whatever firm because then
she can't disambiguate being
um you know modern in the workplace but
then traditional at home
yeah I mean
I just I feel like that's a cope when
they say men are intimidated by money
like I'm okay maybe some men sure it's
Behavior but I I feel like it's more the
way the women treat the men I'm with you
like that's that's just my experience
because in my experience like guys don't
care I don't think it's yeah men are not
intimidated by the money men don't want
to date bad behavior that's really what
it is they don't want to date uh women
that do not respect them as men I
actually my ideal relationship the guy
would be like in charge of money like I
just feel like whether women shouldn't
manage money oh I take
it like listen y'all spend way too much
yeah that's what I'm
even me like I'll see the way guys
negotiate contracts and the way I
negotiate contracts like the amount that
I've taken home is like a lot less than
people think because I suck at the
business side of stuff you need a
manager
shrewd businessman well my dad just
started taking control of my money shout
out to Mr Pearl yeah because I was like
it was I was a couple months in and he's
like you're not making anything what are
you doing and I'm like I'm here to have
fun
it's better now
you were living in your you're living in
your truth the fun Pearl I was like I'm
having a good time Dad that's a good
time if you get paid for your time
that's what my dad told me too yeah
and and then yeah there's a lot of
problems okay so he helped you kind of
get all of the ish up out of the
business all the waste yeah I felt like
I was one of those musical talents
that's like sold all these albums I was
just living
but it wasn't that bad this is just like
a cut like three months you were you
ever figured it out you were first
contract NFL star just bawling balling
do you think that is a bit of a
conspiracy theory I don't want to get
pot from YouTube but do you think
there's a little bit in there where
women are just targeted with the ad like
when you think of like feminism and you
know like kind of uh you know things
that we talked about I don't know like
Cosmopolitan magazine and how they
constructed all of this fake [__] in
order to make money off of women and how
we look at like media today and it's
been Decades of just lying and pandering
to women
offer this and you think that is
predicated off of that women make much
more emotionally based decisions and
then even goes with their money
[Laughter]
and like I'll talk to my dad about oh my
gosh I'll talk to my dad about
like someone like something going wrong
in the business and he's like we'll get
rid of them
I can't no get rid of them yeah yeah all
right and he's like that's not making
you money like yeah and it's so funny
like or even okay the other day I was
talking to a YouTuber about like get
going on different podcasts and he was
like I wouldn't go anywhere if they
didn't pay you and I'm like y'all are
getting paid
and I was like I was like what since
when I got paid for [__] this is
hilarious you know what though I think
this is actually goes into why you've
been so successful is because you didn't
necessarily do it for money you did it
for this is fun and this is content and
I can help yeah and I
was tired when people ask
ing like there's not one rhyme reason
there's like a bunch of different things
like what it was fun two I love
entertainment three I'm really
passionate about YouTube four I I was in
shock when I found out how Society
discriminates against men yeah and I
there's so much stuff that I just didn't
realize like even we were talking
yesterday how you were saying like oh
the women were used like there's so much
language in our society that takes
accountability off of women yeah and
even like even their media yeah the
media yeah there's so much that and I
was just shocked because I just never
it's like once you see it you can't
unsee it you know what was one of my
Revelations I've said this on my channel
before is you ever watched the uh Maury
Show back in the day in the concept of
so Maury Show first started out as just
being a normal kind of like one of them
talk shows and then they started to do
the paternity testing and their ratings
went through the roof now if you watch
the function of the Maury Show woman
comes in
woman doesn't know who the father of her
baby is
hurray which camera zoom in hurray
and meanwhile like if you like it's like
a couple of days a month that you can
take to get pregnant so that means
within less than a week you've had sex
with multiple men right like and think
about the women that had three or four
different guys that they were testing
now they come out what does Maury do oh
we're gonna we're gonna find the father
of little aquan we will find him
the guy number one comes out
audience boo now if you guys never been
on syndicated shows like that the stage
handlers are telling the audience what
to do
so boo he's coming out whatever I ain't
the Pappy bird
a dirty lady
yeah I mean [__] guy number two boo got
number three boo they only cheer when
it's like you know
he's not the the Pappy he didn't want to
be the Pappy that's it but just think
about in my mind watching that is like
10 years old I'm just like okay well
it's the guy's fault
yeah and that's what we always
especially they always put the
accountability on the men yeah for
getting these girls pregnant yeah when
we have 41 forms of birth control we
know when we're calculating you get to
pick who you sleep with talk to her you
it's so it's like if you're sleeping
with these guys that like you know would
not want to be a part like that wouldn't
be in the picture and also what type of
woman are you that these guys don't want
to stick around like that says something
about you as a woman if if these guys
are Dev like okay most guys don't want
an unplanned pregnancy like across the
board but there are some women that you
would be devastated and you would say
okay we can we can work with this you
know and it's like you have these guys
like crying basically that they got you
pregnant what does that say about if
you're a good woman yeah if you're a
good woman that treats these men with
respect right like like they're not
gonna have that reaction they're not
going to want to be deadbeats for the
most part for the most part and and if
they are then why are you sleeping with
them great question Pearl but you're
bringing into that magical a word into
the conversation which has been missing
from mainstream media
for decades now it's crazy it's absurd
it's so interesting we're at a point
where this content is logical it makes
sense yeah but it gets uh so much
negative press and attention so much so
much and it's just like wait a minute
but this this makes sense I'm called a
misogynist and I'm a woman a woman the
nerve of them
didn't they say I hate women which is so
ridiculous we both love women let me
also say after the record as well
because I still get women to come down
into my my damn comment section I love I
love you guys the thing is is like you
know it's similar to having a father
within your life your father's gonna
give you uncomfortable truths
that's what we do
we give uncomfortable truths that's it
all right you may not like us for it but
it's better for you at the end of the
day
that's true absolutely you don't also
want to ask you too go ahead well
actually I wanted to tell you this I was
actually thinking about a way to like
make this um get a lot of clicks okay
and what I was gonna do is I was gonna
uh interrupt you every time that you
talk
in order
to make it seem
like I didn't like you and to imitate
the boy that you had two rounds I don't
know can I say his name
I want to just straight up just
interrupt you know what I'm saying get
married Pearl no like I just want to do
all this the best that I can no no let
me finish let me finish H let me let me
let me finish H I want to talk to H
right now I want to talk to him between
me and eight this is between me and H in
front of millions of people they even
they didn't really know who we're
talking about yeah
yeah sheesh would you ever do a round
three discussion with them can you
answer that and then uh yeah
um I mean look I'm all for the content
if we felt like the problem was
I just wasn't even sure we were debating
because we would be like we I disagree
with the marriage laws today they're
unfair okay so like I'm like okay we're
on the same page but then it just starts
to go personal like you're pandering
anyone that knows me personally knows
that I believe the things I say
sometimes I change my opinion sometimes
I'm wrong we're all human but but I'm
like I believe the [__] that I say
didn't call you Derek Jackson yeah Derek
Jackson or like he compared me and then
he compared me to only fans model I was
just like
his behavior on that first go-round on
round one was so abhorrent I don't know
I don't even know if I would have had a
second conversation with him because it
was so disrespectful yeah well and I
thought the lead attorney was going to
be on with me the second round that's
the thing for a third round like
discussion like what do we disagree on
like that's that's the problem I have is
like we're having a conversation and I'm
cool with that but like I don't even
really know what we're debating yeah
because that wasn't clear it just starts
to be like I don't like the way you do
entertainment I don't like the way like
the red pill doesn't like yeah you
shouldn't you should give advice like
it's just kind of you can't really
debate that his opinion how how you like
something that's yeah that's his opinion
yeah and so it's kind of just that's
that's why I'm saying I think a more
productive discussion would have been
with the lead attorney that's what I
really wanted to bring in because a lot
of times people think that like if men
don't fight in custody for court they
don't want custody of their kids but
like they don't know why they're not
doing that and I felt like the lead
attorney could have spoken to that more
from experience where I'm just like
saying what he said yeah and I'm gonna
butcher this a little bit so but shout
out to the lead attorney I think that he
said that of the 90 that don't file many
lawyers tell the the men not to file
right because by filing it'll be one of
the most expensive losses that you will
incur in your life do you really have
the money to lose when you have a bias
family court system and biased judges
over these over the family court system
right so you know at the end of the day
if you did do round three I'd love to
facilitate we'll make sure we get lead
in there well and the other thing I
didn't realize is you need to do timers
for how long someone can talk because
that's what would happen is like he
would just have all these points and
then I would just be like I I don't even
know what to do with this because you
just talk talk talk talk you know land a
plane brother that's right as well
saying in my reaction did you see my
reaction to it
no your reaction channel is great
actually I I think you're like the best
reactor in the space thank you I really
appreciate that uh you know what's
interesting I mean I could get into a
little bit if you if you would care to
know like the background how the channel
started and stuff like that you know um
actually let me start with like me too
because like this is the first time well
second time technically shout out to the
production team but this is the second
time I went over like my background yeah
um so originally I am from uh Long
Island New York shout out to strong
island in the building
um at 18 I then went and went to Penn
State University for uh undergrad oh let
me also say this as well I am rare
within men in general but also the black
community as well is that I was raised
in a single-parent household by my
father so my parents got split up and
divorced like when I was like seven or
eight or something like that and it was
just me and my pops you know just as a
son and a father you know is living
together you know what I mean like it
wasn't the best cook I've definitely
eaten some steaks that damn near choked
me but it is what it is he did his
absolute best anyway
so went off to Penn State University
um back when I was 18 to do an
undergraduate degree I did it in
um my major was management information
systems which is like a mixture between
business as well as it uh and then on I
went and got an internship at Chase Bank
JPMorgan Chase and then that after my
internship that's how I got to really
start my foray in Corporate America and
I think a lot of people probably uh like
what really like yeah I started off my
career essentially in Corporate America
was a lot different corporate voice I'm
not surprised
like the pronunciation no it's just I
feel like when people work in Corporate
America yeah for a long time I can just
hear it there's a speak there's a that's
why I didn't do well in Corporate
America
I would just give my opinions on things
they'd be like they don't they don't
yeah yeah go back to your
key like there's a certain type of
dialogue there's a certain type of
diction you know like if for example if
you're a flight attendant there's a
certain flight attendant voice yes you
know like if you're a radio personality
depending upon the station there's a
radio personality voice yeah if you're
in corporate
there's a corporate voice yes there's
words that you use I used to have a um a
book that because I get a lot of people
on the channel like yo how do you know
all these words and stuff like that I
used to have a book that I would I would
keep by me and I would write down words
that I would hear and not know so I had
a just a standard and I make sure that
I'd start to use these words in
sentences and then gradual over time it
became a part of my diction which I then
leverage for credibility in the
corporate space yeah maybe I should do
that because there's a lot of big words
out here and I'm just like I don't no I
think the simpler the better from a
platform perspective I think keep it
simple yeah you gotta reach the most
people keep it simple easy words is
better I think it's so you worked in
Corporate America for how long so I was
in Corporate America for I was at Chase
for almost four years and then I went
and I had all my friends next to me you
know upgrading you know whether it be
dope positions or gonna go get business
degrees or whatever degrees law degrees
what have you and I'm like God I wasn't
planning on going back to school but let
me just try to go so I ended up applying
and got a full tuition scholarship to
University of Rochester and Upstate New
York and um which completely changed my
life because at the time I was probably
making somewhere between fifty and sixty
thousand dollars in my mid-ish twenties
uh and then went and got
um this degree spent two years up there
and did the damn thing and
um upgraded that and then that's when I
started in the six figure Club when I
graduated from that institution and I
ended up working in the Midwest for
Nationwide Insurance okay um which
Nationwide I was like hiding you know
because I started my youtubing stuff
when I was still working in Corporate
America so I was doing both at the same
time you know so you know rip to the big
dog Kevin Samuels when he used to say 60
hours per week minimum you know me not
putting in at least 60 hours a week and
I probably argue say I was probably
putting between 80 and 100 when I was
doing both the YouTube channel as well
as
um you know the the corporate experience
at the same time so so yeah so I did
um that during that time for for about
eight years and then I quit back in 2021
like summer of 2021 sometime by then I
had you know been two years into this
type of content in the space so yeah
that's that's the that's the entrance so
that's what
so you're at 25 26 you're making 60 to
70. so these girls are like oh I can't
date a guy that's 60 to 70 like makes 50
to 60 and it's like girl if you just
wait listen well no when I was 26.7 I
was making zero because I was in school
oh okay yeah so that's the thing like
why do girls have these crazy high
standards I didn't understand like the
six figure thing
I just I never really thought about that
but can I can I tell you what yeah well
a degree of it yeah shout out to your
recent interview with those of the likes
of Brittany renners yeah I think media
plays a lot into that when you have
influencers that propagate a certain
type of a lifestyle
um I think it's easy to follow I think
the the feminism a Dogma has shown a
model but what I was thinking about this
I'm like what did I even because I lived
that life like you know what I'm saying
like I grew up in a one percent family
so I was like why why am I the one
that's not thinking about it all these
girls that have never lived that
lifestyle like I've never even been in
the same room with these men ever when
did you get a red pill
oh good question
um
I would say I was more like blue pilled
until I started Kevin Samuel's red
pilled me I didn't like him when I first
saw his content I actually re-watched my
first reaction video I felt so bad I was
like oh so disrespectful like because it
was the one it was he was talking about
a high value men cheat okay and so I
called my dad I'm like Dad where are
your house this man on the internet says
you're cheating
I'm like Dad where are your [__] at
yeah and he's like they've earned the
right to cheat I'm like what yeah and
that was just really different than like
what I grew up with because I just I
realized Kevin talked about there's men
of value in high value men and I think
was my dad was more the men of value
because there's like the type that buys
a piece of land gets a woman and just
doesn't talk to anybody and that's how I
would describe my dad like the LinkedIn
stuff that's not Corporate America he
just started it's like small businesses
does that make sense yeah so like we
didn't really grow up with any of the
stuff he talked about like the escorts
the side [__] like you know like that
just wasn't and the red pill will say
for days and my dad has a side chick and
I just don't know about it look it I I
can't I can't convince people of this so
it's like but you got like nine brothers
and sisters right look at they were busy
yeah they were busy busy could he even
afford a side chick with all of those
mouths to feed I don't know maybe he
just took the family route and just did
it I don't know my dad was like
tell these guys to get one wife before
they try to uh-oh shout out to Mr Probz
but yeah but that's what I think you
know I think like you know so much media
that has lied to women for so long I
mean I didn't think of you know rap
songs and [__] like this I don't Cooks I
don't cleans you know all of this stuff
and it's just like okay you guys are
it's the money method yeah and that is
the thing because I grew up as a tomboy
so a lot of times like you just don't
because I was thinking about I was kind
of raised like a boy a little bit
because I was in sport like I kind of
did boyish stuff most of my life so
um yeah I would say I got red pilled
through Kevin Samuels and then like that
was when I started to see these crazy
women yeah and it's just like when
they're talking about these six-figure
guys I'm like all my brothers make six
figures and none of them would date you
ratchet hoes
shots fired I'm just I'm just like why
on Earth would you guys like won the
guys here like that make six figures
aren't gonna be the guys you expect
because at least my brothers none of
them have like the crazy nice stuff none
of them have like the roll you know what
I'm saying yeah and it's like you
probably wouldn't pick them out from a
crowd but like you would over you would
probably they're nerdy you'd probably
Overlook them and two none of them would
date you you got three ass pictures on
Instagram in the last two days Rebecca
like
like what and he's gonna bring you home
to my mother like oh
that just makes sense and it's like the
other thing is we actually value
accomplishment and I know men maybe
don't care about like that I guess but I
don't know in our family in our similar
circles like you have to have done you
can't have just been doing nothing like
we wouldn't do no they wouldn't take a
girl that's worked at McDonald's like my
brother he's an engineer he married an
engineer like it's just no I yeah I
agree with you yeah I don't know if I
necessarily would at this stage in the
game either
um but I want you know I'm saying like a
smart woman like talented smart along
with all the fit feminine and friendly
but if I can't sit down and just have a
dope conversation with you if you can't
make me laugh like I don't want nothing
to do with you at the end well I want to
say nothing I would be lying hey there's
45 minutes hey she could at least stay
for 45 minutes at least at least are we
going there Pearl
let me also ask you a quick question as
well what did Kevin Samuels mean to you
okay oh
I was gonna ask I asked you the same
thing last time
um Kevin I was the one content creator
like I really wanted to work with
um I
yeah I really looked up to him a lot I
thought his content like I mean it red
pilled me it made me look at the world
in a different way and it really made me
understand like the men around me better
yeah because even like when I go home if
I like cook for my dad like I'll even
try to like cook for my dad more and I
didn't even realize how much like that
means to men you know
um but
I really looked up to him he inspired a
lot of my content and
um
I he gave me good advice I talked to him
I did I did I talk to him you want to
share what you said or was it private
um yeah I'll tell you I was just in a
relationship at the time
um and he just advised me to leave and I
think that was good advice I know a lot
of people are like he tells every girl
to stay
me he was like get out the information
that you shared with him must have been
critical for him to share that type of
advice with you yeah yeah it was
um it was like right after I called into
his show yeah I like out of session with
him and then he was like
I I guess I didn't really realize
he the I guess
because the comments are all gonna be
like you don't have that much leverage I
had more leverage than I than I thought
I guess because he was just explaining
how bad like the dating Market is he's
like you got no kids you have no tattoos
you know like you'll be okay it's not
you don't have to be desperate and like
stay so um I thought that was good
advice and then the second thing was he
helped me with my channel right before
he died so he kind of [__] on my channel
um and he was right though like because
I was doing all this random stuff and it
was just not very organized and he was
just like it was just him like [__]
on me for an hour but I needed it it was
good yeah and then three months later my
channel blew up so yeah perfect ending
today you know because sometimes you
gotta get feedback on things that you
know to get you up out of your comfort
zone because maybe you don't see the
things from another person's perspective
yeah so this beauty he was an amazing
critiqueer an amazing feedbacker you
know I am I think about the several
times that I was able to link up with
him it's just the conversations that we
used to have and um the way that he's
able to pull out all of these disparate
ideas and then to be able to communicate
them with using like examples and he was
a big movie guy I don't know if a lot of
people know that but he was a big movie
guy he pulled all these different movie
quotes
you know and I was just always just like
man like one time I asked him I said man
how do you do that he said I don't know
that's just the way that my mind thinks
he was a Visionary yeah absolutely
that's the thing like there's just
certain people that just think different
yeah and they just see the big picture
and the vision like he he would have
been in Hollywood or something if he if
he didn't pass away I think that's where
he was most likely going to go and I'm
not saying that like he told me like yo
I'm gonna go to Hollywood but I mean
there was only up to go from where he
was only up and the thing is he didn't
even really clip his stuff either so he
like the amount of views and I I think
that doing a live stream monologue is
much harder than a show because I know
it's not a doubt but on with a show I
can rely on other people like if I'm
just not feeling it one day I'll just
ask a question that people can argue
about and I can just sit back yeah just
go through the motion a live stream you
have to be honest and he was so well
researched yeah you could tell he was
talking to these people behind the
scenes and you can't you can't fake that
no and on top of that like he also went
in on the men yeah he was a very fair
like he was very fair yeah like there
were streams that he went in on like the
whip like the men for letting allowing
their women to act a certain way you
know like and that's what I really liked
about him was he he was really a fair
guy honestly but he wasn't afraid to
tell you the truth he wasn't afraid he
told me the truth a couple of times as
well you know what I'm saying let me
tell you
he challenged me a lot on the marriage
thing okay he challenged me a lot on the
marriage thing and and you know we we
had proper conversations regarding that
but um I don't know if you know this but
I talked to him
um the night before he passed
and um
still like kind of messes me up uh
because you know you just never know
when someone in your life is going to go
and um we just had a dope conversation
like the night before it was just like
it was normal and dope what'd you guys
talk about
it was you mean the night before
the night before it was just off of the
strength of
um you know what you got going on this
weekend Oh I got such and such and he
was just talking about like what he had
planned like coming up
um so he started this on his channel
where he would go from different cities
I think he he was in he's got he had
maybe a spot in La a spot in Miami and
then of course he was living in Atlanta
so he'd do these conversations with
these um you know random women I didn't
know who they were you know there's no
disrespect to them if they're people in
social media but he would do this
conversation so he would he we were
talking through how else he was going to
do that going into the future and he
actually said to me as well like listen
man you know I'm gonna need some help
doing these as well like you know let me
know how your schedule is going to be
you know into the future so we talked
about that
um a little bit and then you just got
off the phone he sounded fine you know
same conversation is is we always used
to have but yeah I used to talk to him
damn near almost uh
you know every day did he give you like
dating advice what dating so I told you
the dating advice he gave me and what
dating advice did he give you
oh gosh come on I told you I told you he
well I talked to him about young one
young lady okay
um I was in and around my space at that
time and to be honest with you I was
there were some things about her that
didn't make her an exceptional fit for
me but Kevin was actually huh what was
it I didn't like her social media
presence okay her social media presence
is what I talk about on the channel was
it inappropriate yes oh she had for me
it was inappropriate what did she have
on
it's just good for like the women to me
it's from the guy's point of view you're
you your ass should not be in the video
oh yeah duh even to me with pants on
yeah but if you have on the Spandex and
[__] like that it shouldn't you
shouldn't be bending down in front of
the camera twerking this that in the
third like it's all modern women [__]
can I see the video
ever I just want to see
who wants to get in there you will see
what I'm into is that what's going on
bro
Jesus
I want to see like how bad is like to I
don't know where is the line for most
men I just wanted to see if it was far
past it we needed we need to do a
reaction video together where we
actually look at videos and then
determine and determine the line yeah
because you know a line for me is
probably not gonna be alive for everyone
I was actually you know shout out to
Millie Monica I just did a stream with
her because I'm just surprised you'd
even you'd even deal with a girl and to
start that you need advice on that yeah
yeah well you know but that's the thing
though is that so many men are taught
within the feminized media today that
the more skin that they show or the
freakier that they act the better that
they are for you so much so that these
young men are convinced to take these
half naked women out to the club to
allow them to go on Instagram and show
their body with no repercussions are you
included did you feel like that at a
point yeah
myself but you know but to get back
because so I actually just had a guest
uh Millie Monaco on the show and that's
one of the comments that were down up in
there is to say well she shows Skin and
Body up on the stream is that like
really someone who would be in your
options set of dating and the thing is
is like I think that we've lied to
Modern women long enough and told them
that men don't care about that so much
so that the young men of today are
brainwashed into thinking that they do
care about that goes against our
competitive nature see there it I always
thought was I never
wanted anything that my kids could see
because like even when I was younger
like before the whole YouTube like I
just didn't want anything that my kids
could see someday because like the
internet's forever and you don't want
your kids to you know isn't there a
video of is it cardi B who like her
daughter was like listening to one of
her songs and they got her own video
like turning it off real quick while the
daughter was there they're appropriating
sexuality they really are for this for
money it's crazy it's gross right just
like and and the sad part is I'll like I
was on a show with these only fans girls
and I would probably give them hard
six oh you give them sixes like
adjustable sixes yeah but adjustable
sixes
can still like get attention from the
type of guys like because because the
West is so bad right and I was like
telling them I'm like you probably have
a look that a lot of guys like that are
in the category because they wanted like
six figure guys whatever I was like
you're probably cute enough to get their
attention but because you put your body
on the internet recreational use and now
you're officially record like you can't
undo that yeah and I said it's
unfortunate because you Pro if you
didn't go that route you like honestly
most girls are overweight most girls
have kids most girls have tattoo like if
you went a different route you might
have actually been able to pull that off
you're naturally feminine which a lot of
girls like even meme like I was raised
as a boy so like me myself I struggle
with that and I'm like but you guys went
this route and now like you're kind of
screwed and you can't undo it no it's
like walking around with a tattoo on
your face yeah you know because your
digital footprint is just as permanent I
mean the same thing applies so the thing
is is like again logical stance yeah the
same thing is within trying to get a job
right so it's just like you acquiesce
for the job but you know acquiesce when
it comes to dealing with men today you
know the way that you conduct yourself
should be a reflection of who you are as
a person if you conduct yourself like
that knowing that men don't value that
outside of just trying to get the
viscous innards from you then really
what is the benefit so I want to ask you
another question as well okay go ahead
is Brittany Renner really changed
um I think
maybe had some changes in her mindset a
little bit but I don't think you can
really do the work to really change 10
years of programming in a couple months
so I would say
um do I think that
do I think a hose can be saved in
general no a lot of people come at me
and say the wife's school like but do I
think they could hypothetically I mean
I'm a big believer you can do anything
you set your mind to I'm with you um I
don't think most men will forgive you
for that checkered of a past yeah I
don't think you're gonna get the same
guy you could get at 22. yeah but I do
think a lot of hoes or girls that have
had these past configure something out
yeah however I don't think most want to
put in the work to actually learn how to
serve a man
I I don't and has she done that has she
really learned what men value and really
started to become that has she pulled
the ass pictures off of Instagram has
she pulled has she really started
learning to cook um I she could go that
route
um and I'd be happy to support her if
she wants to but I just don't think you
know saying a couple nice words means
you've changed you gotta get on the
wife's school I I'm more than willing to
get her in the wife school I'll work
with anyone I'm a just big believer in I
like people that try yeah so if you try
like [__] I think lot's possible if you
try I think that she was caught up in
the wave of what we were talking about
earlier which is the media that
appropriates so somebody and she modeled
a component of her lifestyle off of like
super head who wrote a book right like
she took some things out that Playbook
and then went forward with it and you
know now that she has a son and now that
you know she's hit the wall I think that
she's assessing where her career can go
into the future and also just real quick
also too I think that she said she was
starting a podcast so it's just like if
you want to start a podcast at post wall
in this now new men's internet
environment and still be doing the same
things that you were doing 10 years ago
it's probably not going to get as many
clicks as many views like it'll be good
for me to react to like if you still
want to do it that way go ahead Mama but
I think that it's
um she's taking not only and probably
also saying you know do I want my son to
wife up someone who
um you know portrays what this is you
know who I portrayed myself to be in the
past and I think that she's just taking
a step back and she's saying let me just
go down this path because now she
because she can have a you know two of a
Rags the richest type of a story in
transitioning into this type of content
which makes a lot more logical sense for
the continuation of
the business I think we still
take accountability off of women when we
say the culture made them do it okay
because I really do think that women
enjoyed the attention yes that it gave
them yes so
um I while I do think the culture
doesn't help and maybe it doesn't show
the consequences like I still want to
put it on the women because there's a
lot of us that grew up in the culture
and didn't make those decisions I'm with
you but you know but if Brittany Renner
grew up in Sudan
she would not be Brittany Renner so it's
like the culture enabled the behavior
and then the money enabled
and honestly I just think at the end of
the day
I told you this last time I think
there's no consequences
um
like none like I just think at the end
of the day like
like there's always someone to bail you
out there's gonna be always someone yeah
oh yeah if you're attractive enough as a
young woman yeah that seems to always be
some some like white nights
this is the term I've learned beta beta
off
[Applause]
another question
um how do you feel about Andrew Andrew
is really nice and polite yeah um I had
a good experience with him yeah
um you think he's guilty I mean I don't
know the definition of human trafficking
yeah
um I thought if you were able to leave
that you weren't guilty this is just
what I know based on the facts of the
case yeah it's possible there are more
facts that I don't know that'll come out
yeah I'm not going to act like I had a
super close relationship to the guy like
some of the guys in the space have known
him for years and they'll die on that
Hill that he didn't do anything yeah I
only met him once he was very nice to
meet like that that's my experience with
him I my gut is telling me he's not
guilty yeah it's possible there's more
facts
um and it seems like the girls were
always allowed to leave I think if you
were allowed to leave that shouldn't be
human trafficking but I think the
legally yeah they're able to say that he
did because he tried to make them fall
in love or something and that's like
coercion but it's like
does that make sense so I don't know if
legally he might be guilty I don't know
yeah
I am I want him not to be guilty I think
it's like this I think if you like
Andrew Tate you think that he's innocent
and if you don't like Andrew Tate you
think that he's guilty I think that
there's that structure that's happening
I want him not to be guilty right with
every fiber and being of my soul I want
that to happen
at the same time I think
I don't know did you see the video that
he has where he's talking about
um how he got the women to go from
wherever they were located at to the one
Roman I saw was like he was dating that
it was like all his girlfriends and then
he had them all come and then they said
like he told them what was going to
happen and half of them laughed yes so
there's that but then I think also tied
to his Hustler University don't quote me
on that I think that it was there he had
a video where he essentially was
teaching people how to set up his
operations and with in his description
he talked a lot about how to control
these women and essentially he was
comparing himself to like a street pimp
and then saying things in our words that
would lead me to conclude that he viewed
himself as a digital pimp and the thing
is is that like I agree you're you don't
have to go if someone's asking you to go
you don't have to go but I think it gets
a little bit weird when he's emitting on
screen the mental tactics that he would
do in order to ensure that they would
never stay like one of the things that
he mentioned in the video is is that he
would
um
essentially tell the girls that he was
paying them 50 50 50. and uh but he
wasn't he was paying them 70 to 30 and
was telling the girls that the extra 20
was going towards taxes and they weren't
but like he had missed this on the video
so it's just like it's it's I wanted to
be innocent I want him to be that's not
the same to me but like this is just how
I feel like
it's called it's not the same thing as
human trafficking so but if you break
down what human trafficking is it's like
three different terms it's like coercion
fraud right and there's one other and
that's what I was saying I think there
might be a technicality that's the
technicality yeah the technicality in
that I think is fraud yeah so the tax
fraud stuff would be separate but the
idea that most you know if you if you
want to say this is that women don't
like to file their taxes so he would say
I know I'm doing your taxes don't worry
about it I'm doing it they're too hard
for you to do they're too hard I got
them so they would feel like well if I
want to keep on making this money maybe
this is something I would stay outside
of the fraud of it not being the amount
that they agreed to could have she could
have fought like I just feel like that's
your own fault you could have filed your
own like I'm just an accountability
person me too then file your own taxes
I'm with you yeah but the technicality
of in the definition of human human
trafficking to include fraud is
I want him to be innocent I want him to
be but that's what they do with men they
like broaden the definitions of like
grape of like essay like they brought in
the definition so broad that it's so
easy to like kind of catch men on like a
catch-22 on something and I think that
almost speaks to like how unfair the
legal system is against men like I heard
they and the other thing that they don't
talk about is are were the women
committing fraud when they were
convincing these men to send them money
Knowing damn well that they were never
gonna sleep with them or talk to them or
do anything with them because they there
are points where Tate said like he would
get the women to
you know get men to send them their life
savings yeah but were they being coerced
Hey listen if I was elected in the
office I'd make a law for foodie calls
put me up there and I'll be one of the
first let's do mandatory DNA testing for
men let's do that one first and let's
let's all of the 40 calls I see y'all
I'm coming for y'all MTR 2024 what up
what up yeah I'll do your I'll do your
shorts for your for your campaign you
promise you promise you know I got an
issue uploading shorts I appreciate that
yeah wow we can we can pinky swear all
right all right can we can we yeah yeah
all right cool boom y'all y'all are
seeing it in line campaign manager there
it is there it is yeah we could probably
make content over that what we we could
do like we make another Channel MTR and
Pearls campaign 2024. we talked about
the your Bachelor series yo what's up
bro I'm with it come on what's up tell
them tell them what we're talking about
in the car all right so listen let me
know down in the comment box down below
what you guys think about this okay
y'all know like the bachelor right like
normally they put them on like an island
or something I don't know I've never
seen it I'm just taking a guess but
imagine putting me in a house
and then we have all of these women and
be like Brittany Runner we'll put you on
Brittany Brittany what's up I got you
girl it'll be like 20 20 women like 12
hoes
Three Chicks belugas if you will
you know what I'm saying feminist two
feminists all right we might need like
30 or so girls because the first show
will be like get get all 27 and a half
of these women out of here I want no
Puck we'll have a scale for the first
part of the tassels
you can't shape where his ass
oh [__]
where's his ass oh you can't and and
we're gonna have them break themselves
one to ten anyone that thinks they're
ten get out of it if you delusional get
out of here I want no parts to you do
you have an only fans
sex work Haram get out of here get them
out of here Pearl and I would like to
see you drag them out I don't know if
you can I don't know they might get sued
for that but like I would love to see
that'll be so entertaining Pearl's just
dragging the girls get out of here I'm
just I'm just trying to facilitate love
here
get an Airbnb for a day
maybe when are we going to Studio in the
U.S yeah
I think we got a trillion dollar idea
right there look it I've no one's really
done like a red pill Bachelor yo son so
you can't do a red pill Bachelor because
I was like it's not red pill if all the
men are chasing the women yeah you know
what I'm saying so I was like you can't
yeah you can't it's got to be the man at
the time yeah Millie Monaco on there yo
yeah we could put Meli up on there I'm
sure she will be down but you know
mainstream TV would never host that so
we'd have to do it on YouTube YouTube
YouTube absolutely we could play I could
be bad cop you could be good cop you
know I can go off and then you try to
bring and when you at the end you have
life life lessons you bring up a white
board in front of them you're like no no
on February 23rd 2022 you posted this
goddamn this thong picture he saw it get
out of here right like that's what I
think you should that we could do like a
case where we sit down and they can give
up the case for why they posted the
picture and you could deem it acceptable
or unacceptable trillion dollar idea I'm
trying to tell you bro listen we gotta
get that problem I have so many of these
I swear to God every day your creativity
knows no bounds no bounds that's the
people have no idea like how create like
how many ideas I just have for even the
future of like stuff I'm gonna do in the
next year but here's the thing ideas of
[__] unless you execute on them I'm an
Executor you're an Executor you gets it
done I really want to do the bad don't
tempt me the problem had so much work
but you know if the comments want to
help me recruit we just need to don't we
just need a donor a donor yeah like
someone to come in and put a whole bunch
of money into it you know what I mean
and someone oh my God it will go crazy
we get a dope Airbnb and imagine like a
live stream all of it and get get dorms
yeah and and they get judged and how
clean they can keep their space Oh My
Gosh the girls can kick someone off by
saying that she's not clean enough like
whoever's the worst to live with we
can't have you with a messy chick can we
do food taste testing yeah yeah oh my
God I'm always going into start slapping
plates off the tables maybe this will be
an episode of wife's school where we
have everyone come in have it had me oh
my God I would oh I forgot to tell you
get like single bachelors in the
manosphere
uh-oh we gotta get a whoo let's talk
about it there's a who who's single
um okay I want the guys they have to be
single no kids good job so
um you the lead attorney the lead
attorney
um [__] who else and they can't
some of y'all have been too public with
these I want multiple wives thing yeah
but maybe I just think this would be
harder well maybe season two would two
with a polygamy one maybe the multiple
miles yeah we got to get through season
one season one I'm going too far in the
future for you I'll try to strategize
episode
he's like
it was good I really get through season
one it's got to be a dope Airbnb
Mansion man I I said daughter I'm an
investor investor I need an investor
what's up it's a lot of those dudes with
money out there I've had investors
contact me really yeah but I didn't
really understand it so I was like well
why would I give it to you I could just
go to my dad click
my dad was like but my dad was just like
maybe you should have taken that call
damn bro [__] I didn't understand it I
didn't really know yeah oh my God that's
invitable mission to do in business
that's how we feel every day oh gosh
that's why you need a business manager I
know get all of your costs under wrap
I'm trying to tell you yeah we gotta
talk about it all right now we're
working on it we're working on it well
you guys are doing a fantastic job and
shout out to the jpt crew that's out
there yeah shout out you guys shout out
shout out I'd like to give a shout out
to Nigeria just because they really
carry the back of the channel hey that's
what's up oh see your production guys
the the Clippers are in editors yeah
it's like Nigeria Mexico
um
it do we still have a guy from India
India
Zimbabwe zimba I love Zimbabwe in the
building yeah and the quality is still
good yeah yeah and if it's not good they
work so hard they yeah they're
phenomenal I have so much respect like
honestly I love my team you have a
business mind I do you're you're
Outsourcing yeah I mean I grew up it's
not one thing like give me like even if
you're a girl it's like I still grew up
with my dad you know what I mean like I
can't okay you're speaking of
Outsourcing have you heard about the
passport Bros yeah what's your thoughts
on the I think that we should learn from
the women overseas instead of whining
that they're leaving why don't we ask
why they're leaving and maybe try to
model some of the stuff like a lot of
girls will come at me and they'll be
like well you're not married you still
struggle in day of course I do yeah what
do you mean I was a tomboy but you can
learn why would you not look at the
women that are attracting the most men
yeah and the highest quality men which
arguably some will say that they're not
but you know that's not mine why don't
we take lessons from them where the men
are saying the women are the best to
date yeah why don't we look at them and
say what can we learn but instead
they'll be like oh they ain't [__]
they're they're the men we don't want
anyway
pointing the finger outwards as opposed
to pointing it where it needs to that's
what I'm saying we could we could learn
something yeah we could get we could
start running get on the treadmill you
know what I mean like absolutely learn
how to cook look I've been learning
jollof rice
it's like um it's it's like a Nigerian
food it's really good though
and look at you can let me ask you a
quick question on that Pearl how do you
season it how do I season how do you
season the rice all right well it it
depends it depends how spicy you want to
make it I like to put you have to blend
the like stuff together and I like to
put a lot of spice so I like to put do
you yes do you know what Lowry's is oh
God I love that I wouldn't use that for
July price but I do love Barbies I
prefer
I really like to mix Cajun and cayenne
those are like my favorite spices okay
okay just as long as you don't put salt
pepper on it and then walk away we can't
we can't have you doing that out here
okay okay fantastic
fantastic okay I have a question for you
okay what wait just real quick did we
finish the passport Bros thing oh sorry
I'm a woman we get off Gotta Give Them
structure sometimes I think that
passport Bros I understand why they're
leaving
um I've been following this one guy that
went to Brazil he seems to be living his
best life that's what's up
um so I understand why they're doing it
yeah um I think you're gonna have a lot
of issues like I think sometimes like
you're gonna have issues with two
different cultures yeah but the women
seem nice enough that they'll figure it
out yeah
um I say good luck go do it when I've
gone abroad and I've been to like 12 to
13 different countries
um when I've gone abroad
this is why I tell so many of the people
that the dudes that watch my channel get
out y'all blocks get out childhoods get
out your neighborhoods get out your
cities get out your States and get out
the country you have to travel you have
to see more than what's put in front of
you please for the love of everything
holy please when I go outside of the
country it's like I there's another
layer of love that I get there's just
another layer this is another letter now
it will change you know I'm saying like
I've been all around Western Europe and
stuff like that and um like Germany for
example when I go down to Germany women
come up to me oh I've lived in Germany
you lived in Germany yeah they they love
like black guys yeah
I'm like holy German
Thailand had me feeling like a um a
monarch yeah I'll just be walking
through the streets and just all the
things that I would have just be like oh
man is this women hate the cat calling
but I think that I like it would you
ever like marry a girl and bring her
back here or like bring a girl back from
one of those countries well the key word
in there was the word Mary okay I don't
know about long term yeah uh I if I did
I'd have to figure out a way not to turn
on the TV in front of her
because then she would be exposed to the
Mind mail that is mainstream media in
society today
um so I'd have to think about that and
you know like we did that conversation
with the old man's girl and
um it came out at the end of it that her
soon-to-be fiance is in Argentina my
next initial thought was was he doing it
for citizenship because why would you
want to date the only fans girl unless
there was something else big on the
other side of it you know so I I you
know at the end of the day there's a
component of
um nature that I'd have to continue to
avoid but what I will say is I support
the passport Bros get out of the country
I support you guys
also at the same time it's not in my
purview to go over there and get a woman
to bring back like I'm I'm cool I'm I'm
having fun as it is right now
well I just I always am curious because
it seems like you would have the same
issues when you brought them back
because the girls would be so much
better than the ones here they would
just be flooded with attention I think
instead of bringing them back like why
not just stay over there
do most people want to is the question I
think a lot of Americans think that
America is better than what it actually
is I think I think until people go
abroad and see the awesomeness of the
different nations of the different
cultures don't get me wrong I love
America yeah I love America but um
there's some things that we have to
worry about here that we just think is
just normal
and that are not um issues elsewhere I
don't know
I've lived in Germany I've lived in
England
um I haven't really lived in southern
countries so maybe that's where the
disconnect is like Brazil Mexico like
I've never lived somewhere like that but
honestly like living overseas makes me
miss America so much more yeah because
it's just so much easier to do things
there here you don't need to like like I
remember in Germany you had to apply for
like a permit to go boating like in the
US you can just grab put take your boat
and like go on the Mississippi No One's
Gonna Do anything like it's just
I don't know I grew up with nannies that
like wanted to come here so bad some of
the some of y'all married my cousins
let's not talk about that let's not talk
about that Natalia
Natalia is that is that someone that's
on the show no that's the nanny I had as
a kid though because my cousin and then
divorced him oh the nerve of her yeah I
mean granted he was kind of crazy too
like it was it was kind of like a match
made yeah that was that was yeah but I
don't know so I'm cool with at some
point saying I'm okay with traveling
abroad and maybe staying places for long
periods of time you know I think that
this is gonna be pros and cons
everywhere I think like there's people
that's trying to come over here from
abroad and it's people that are looking
at where we're at right now and trying
to go abroad and you know I think like
at the end of the day it's subjective
depending upon your goals in life who
you are as a person and what you're
looking for you know like one of the
things that I talked about the dudes in
the channel at least I'm gonna ensure
that I do more into the future is the
importance of you know your tribe your
community the relationships that you
build and if you find that most of those
in the general area that are beside you
are keeping you or holding you back then
what is stopping you from going abroad
and that's just my thing many of people
that are forming the opinions on why men
should not go abroad have never even
been abroad
they've never even gone outside of their
own neighborhoods I'll tell you I grew
up with nannies from around the world
they're better they're better than us
you shoot everyone you're shooting Clips
look at and pearl myself she had a
machine gun this whole stream I look at
if a man if a man left me for a Latina
chick I would understand oh look if we
should just learn we should just take
notes and try to get better oh [__] so
we can bet I'm an athlete ladies let's
compete uh-oh let's just try to get
better that's all you can do holy moly
like you can't help where you start but
you can always try to get better uh-oh
so I don't understand why don't we just
try to get better
it's a great question well we live in a
victim Society we live in a oh whoa is
me poor me
shut your mouth get back you know the
one that really pisses me off it doesn't
really piss me off because I try not to
get angry in 2023.
um women that complain about being an
alpha in the workplace but then being
feminine at home is it really that tough
absolutely is it really
you're not you're not an alpha at work
you're a feminine woman or you're not a
feminine one I'm sorry like the most and
I'm not even going to use my like okay
I'm gonna use the most feminine girls I
know where I think of and I'm like that
is the model of femininity yeah there is
nothing you could do to have them be in
those jobs that they're masculine if you
get a masculine job it's because you're
masculine and they don't want to it's
always oh well he puts me in my
masculine let's talk about none of these
girls want to go down in lifestyle to
stay home I know girls that are dating
guys that make over six figures they
still want to work because they want to
travel they want to do all this stuff
like you could go down in lifestyle and
stay home
I think if you're a feminine woman you
could still be a good actor within the
workplace though right like you could
you can be feminine at heart you could
want to do all of the dope ass things
that make masculine guys want to
maintain you in a relationship but I
think you can also go into the workplace
that doesn't mean you're gonna be
partnering at a law firm because it's
probably not going to rub you the right
way having to make all these masculine
decisions when your basis is femininity
but it you know it don't mean that you
know you can be the boss chicks the real
boss chicks I agree they're just
masculine at their core and they just
ride with this feminism independent
woman boss chick [__] that has put them
up in a on a pedestal for the past
several decades but you can up in the
workplace in a feminine way I'm with you
so like I worked in sales that's a very
male dominated field yeah but it's like
you can go about selling things in a in
a more feminine way or you can do it
like a dude and I I would just do like I
would just do it in a more feminine way
but the dudeway is going to get you
better results true that's really what
the that's true so so when when you're
in sales and you're comparing when it's
just a numbers organization you need the
masculine characteristics you need
second attempts you need third attempts
actually
a lot of girls get things sold come on
oh they do it's just what do you think
but they also confront
I mean they're hot they do their thing
but they won't stop on the first they
won't be agreeable and say oh you know
what okay okay fair enough fair enough
they'll get active yeah
the good ones yeah yeah that's so it's
like well how do you compete with men
maybe I shouldn't be talking
you quit you quit your uh yeah do they
do they know that yet yeah I don't I'm
I've talked about it on the channel like
I had a I mean I have so many new
subscribers they probably don't but I
had a sales job and I had one Tick Tock
of viral and I was like yeah I'm
quitting yeah boom wait after one one
yeah I had one viral Tick Tock and then
I was like yeah where's the camera after
one tell you what happened so
um it was the summer it was steering but
I just remember I was living with these
people from my church and I had a Tic
Tac where I told a story about my family
go viral got like four million views I
got 20 000 tick tocks followers and I
was just like I think I'm good at this
stuff and I was and I started making a
plan about how I was gonna quit and so I
decided I was gonna play overseas and I
was gonna I quit like it was July I
think I quit a month or two later but
I'd already stopped working so I was
just like I just made a plan but you
said no but yeah stop getting quiet
sales so you can kind of okay I was like
I'll ride this for a month or two and
then yeah I didn't even tell my parents
I was moving home I just like showed up
with my stuff I'm like I'm here
um and and yeah my mom was not excited
but uh
the sea
that delayed a year yeah so I just like
was decided that I was gonna do instead
of getting a job I was just gonna work
on Tick Tock and YouTube for a year and
then okay um it didn't blow up till I
got to London but I just I really just
wanted to make enough money so I could
do the volleyball thing and YouTube at
the same time so like supplement but
yeah yeah can I can I tell you that you
just triggered me a little bit why the
amount of
um
uh women that I've dated in my past that
have been trying to make squirrely
decisions and I'm trying to give them
structure
I'm trying to give them framework yeah
I'm trying to get you know but you're
just like one viral Tick Tock I'm out of
this yeah well um I feel it I feel like
stuff works out for me because you're an
idea person and an Executor yeah because
I do it but so many girls will just quit
and do nothing and they'll be like why
aren't I
you build different do you think that
that's mostly lent to you having a
father at home or you being an athlete
I think it's having parents that taught
me like certain mindsets so like knock
on every door like one time when I first
started my YouTube career I went door to
door in rich neighborhoods yeah and just
started to see it ask for jobs I just
wanted to see I didn't want a job I was
unemployed and I was happily unemployed
but I went door-to-door in rich
neighborhoods I just wanted to see if I
could get a job in a day just to test it
and everyone will be like oh it's
because you're a woman oh it's cause
you're white I'll do it with anyone I
bet you I bet you this would work I
would put money for anyone come with me
to Rich a rich neighborhoods go knock on
their door say do you know anyone hiring
this is what I do give them a resume I
got offered a job in a day well I
offered an interview one day content we
should do it yeah we should film it yeah
I'm I'm 100 down because like people
that are successful respect people like
like okay imagine if you had some maybe
not knock on your home door but if you
if you were in that situation right and
someone was just going door to door in
your neighborhood right and they they
gave you a resume that was something
that you did or you knew someone hiring
like you probably would help them out
because you respect the hustle it
increases the likelihood of them getting
the the intended outcome that they're
looking for yeah I also got I went in
Milwaukee I
um called c-level Executives to see
because because I was in the sales
registry I had the phone numbers of a
lot of these like Executives or like
their business lines so I just called
them and see if they to see if they
would hang out with me so um I got the
CIO of Harley-Davidson and then the CIO
of I think it was We Energies and these
are billion dollar companies to just get
coffee with me you're a grinder yeah and
that castle share something with them
yeah oh my God so
on Instagram
I didn't know that there's your inbox
there's like the the messages of people
who you don't accept as friends but then
there's also a hidden message list
I found this out about two so months ago
I tried to reach out to Pearl one day
and I look into it
and there's about 20 to 30 messages
she she went to my hidden messages list
but I'm bringing out to say
I'm assuming this is when you add less
subscribers than me but there was 20 or
30 messages
yep I would send
a reactors I would say like people the
different links yeah to react to stuff
because that's how people go virals like
they're real they react to it yeah yeah
and they always come back later they
always come back around they might leave
you on scene to start yeah but they'll
come back I'm sure there's a lot of
people that's hitting you up now that
you leaving on scene boy boy boy boy boy
crazy scene delivered deny but that's
the thing like I never took it personal
yeah so like that mindset of like
knocking every door like always ask for
opportunities forgiveness not permission
like because a lot of people are afraid
to message someone 20 times I don't care
that's an ego thing like you're afraid
that they're gonna not like you like who
cares what how do we fit you know it's
it's such a there's a poison pill of
entitlement there's a poison pill of
participation trophies there's a poison
pill of weakness
what can we do to turn this around I
just I don't think you can that's why I
say I don't give advice and because I
just don't
comes from within yeah and like you
can't really change the world you can
change your world yeah and that's that's
just a personal like people that I
wanted to get good at YouTube and it was
helpful to have different people I could
look to and get advice from but I would
have did it either way yeah you know
what I'm saying like it has to come from
within it does but I do think it's
helpful to have resources so I'm not
against the self-help I'm not against
any of that stuff yeah but
um well listen I got some resources
which camera this one I got some
resources
modern man's playbook.com listen at the
end of the day there's a lot of
different
places that you can gather information
from especially if you are a young man
and you're trying to become the man that
every man respects and the man that
every woman wants y'all already know
where to find me I think either you
could look out to all of the internet
and see all of this different
information and go video after video
after video but you have if you have an
easily to access indexable version of
the information that focuses on your
mental frame of origin your masculinity
your finances your philosophy your
purpose your why in order to make the
best version of yourself going into the
future go up to that link and check me
out guys
and also also DM me if you want to be on
The Bachelor
if you're a woman and you're thinking
wow I'm very interested here damn DM
Pearl for to be on The Bachelor what's
up mama just look at my content first no
actually don't look at my content first
because then the hoes ain't gonna show
up look at we can have some wifey girls
in the mix like come on yeah hit Perla
all right Pearl's gonna be my Tyler
manager you have to start with telling
me your body count oh god well you know
you have to multiply by three right
multiply it by three whatever they tell
you really three
yeah
maybe four what's the most common do you
ask girls that body count yeah
the girls who are dating uh no like I
don't I don't ask what I do is I run the
the hofax the whole fact yeah
um so you know who who where was she at
if she just comes into town and you
don't know her background at all just
multiply by four right but if you know
people you know the connections you know
you could do like a little bit of
research in order to figure out like
what it is I was just curious like what
the most common number they tell you is
under 10
okay so what did they say they say under
attack usually oh okay yeah I mean you
get some of the truthful ones that will
give their actual roundabout you know
and it's truth be told you never know
and that's the thing is like to your
comment earlier is that there's no
repercussions at the end of the day you
can move States you know and you know
not and just say that you didn't have
friends in this prior state so then you
don't got like circles to contact or hit
up oh and true okay no I was gonna say
though but I think that it's so
important to figure out because you know
thinking back to
um the more partners that she has the
more likely that divorce might happen if
marriage is on the ticket for you know
some of these fellas no I know that's
the thing like I don't understand why
girls will push so hard so hard on body
count why they don't want to give it or
why they divide it I mean like why
then girls know it matters
what's the first thing you call another
girl when you go yeah so you know
innately in your hind brain that body
count matters and you're gonna you're
gonna judge the men for caring when we
care about all this stuff like they're
allowed to have standards they're
allowed to care yo how about how they
judge men for you know interacting with
sex workers but then big up IG models or
only fans models I've never thought
about that don't judge the men that yeah
for getting it popping isn't that so
crazy there's so much of this [__]
okay tell that oh tell them about your
red pill moment oh God I actually have a
video on my Channel about this but I'll
go over a condensed short version story
because I don't want to bore you guys so
I will say like um you know anyone's
doing content in the space I would say
would have different moments of uh red
pulling but I mine came way before I was
even a content creator at all
um mine came which is how I guess most
people look at the content in the space
it comes to which is someone did them
wrong some chick did them wrong I got
done wrong I was up on a college campus
this chick told me that she has ovarian
cancer so essentially lied to me that
um you know I can't
have intercourse with you because of my
doctor's appointments and the things
that they give into that in the third
but then went and found out later that
she was Tom Dick and Harry
yeah this is on a college campus you
never slept with her no no I did no no
no stop sleeping with you yes so she
stopped at that so it was like a year
and a half a half relationship like
around there I would say this the cancer
thing came up about a year into it but
she I was so blue pill I was so
believing I was so trusting that like
she was saying dude said different
things and I'd be like okay let me give
a couple examples
um there was one time I walked by the
computer and on the computer was like
her burst like the registrar like her
grades and [__] and she told me she was
like 3.8 GPA
meanwhile she wasn't even going to class
like that so I should have known
something was up but I was just so
believed
spice it every
Time Podcast uh-oh shots fired I'm not
gonna shots I'm not gonna name names but
some of y'all uh oh Pearl's on one today
we gotta do more of these Pearl we I'll
be getting you off off your oh yeah I've
been nice for a year oh I'm tired she
left the hair done around your boy I'm
tired of the women I'm tired of
everybody
one guy told me about his business and
we looked it up it was dissolved like
you realize these are puppies oh no I
recently just moved into a new city
that's known for scammers and [__] like
that I'm not gonna say what the city is
because a lot of crazy people out there
but um yeah it's a it's a thing where
people lie to get we gotta get more
Focus look at you you get me off center
I'm structure structure Pearl I can't
let's bring it back yeah I'm not a yeah
let's bring it back okay so anyway this
Heathen of a young lady okay uh I said
she was a lie to me you know about you
know what she was doing with her time
telling me that she couldn't with me and
then meanwhile here's how I found out
because I'm sure people like well how
did he find out uh so back in the day
before you were born there was a program
called AOL Instant Messenger and on this
program you couldn't save chat history
but during the time this is like 2000
and 2003 or something two one something
like that Facebook was just new
um but anyway um you could save chat
history with another program called Dead
aim and so I enabled dead aim just to
have chat history logs I thought it'd be
beneficial so one day she was using my
computer
a couple weeks if not a month later I
was looking at the computer at the chat
history and I'm sure she was typing so I
clicked down up into it
and then the truth was revealed uh you
know based on the conversations that was
being had so I would say like from that
instance the ideals of
work on me
get better faster bigger stronger at the
time I was like a decent student I mean
if I applied myself a little bit more I
probably would have gotten even better
grades
but you know I always consider myself
like intermediately smart you know I
never really did like tremendous on
standardized test test or anything like
that
um but you know I was kind of just
chilling doing my thing having fun I
mean I was at a major institution and
even at being at a major institution
with all of these women I got into this
relationship where I'm my least valuable
she's at her most valuable at the time
you know what I'm saying and then I got
Bamboozled I got Tricks so then I
started to think how can I be my most
valuable right how can I work in on
myself to build true confidence true
utility within the life and I just got
down deep and then that's when I got the
internship that's when I got the job I
started flipping it and it was just one
flip after the next time she come
crawling back funny story
so after it all got outed she never came
back to campus
because she was so she was so much of a
manipulator and it's the thing as well
too is that like I didn't know that
human nature can be that Sinister that
diabolical that Abyss level
but she was so good at her manipulation
that she essentially constructed her
friends to not like me so the friends
wouldn't tell me that she was doing
whatever she was doing and then at the
same yeah that's pretty much so she was
that manipulative like with it you know
what I'm saying but um
I know that it was all a lie because I
eventually became friends with someone
that she knew years before who said that
oh yeah she used to like you know you
you know lie that she had cancer to her
professors in order to like get out of
tests and [__] like that like just
another level of [__] so anyway in the
kind of when I got out the red pill rage
stage and this is even before like the
Matrix came out right I would have rage
if a girl lied to me about cancer what
the hell yeah yeah yeah no I was in a
deep I was in a deep red state for a
long time cancer yeah it was crazy you
know just like someone that can do that
is just crazy I'm not upset at her you
know I'm Healed and [__] from that and I
think that all dudes that go through the
red pill rage should figure out how to
get up out of it you don't want to stay
in it for forever because I think it
breeds nihilism it breeds content it
breeds negativity so you got to figure
out how to get to the next stage beyond
that but at the same time though I began
to involve myself in like more
destructive behavior and
I would because I had to see for myself
like
are women really like this and I
remember to this day being in women's
Apartments doing what I do looking at
pictures of them in relationships on the
banister
and it just blew my mind like so so I
began to engage in all this negativity
I'm trying to make sure we don't get any
monetized wait wait
wait wait go ahead
so you you'd go to the girls apartments
with the boyfriends no not with the
boyfriends just me and the girl the girl
was cheating thank you for clarifying
I'm cheating with you yes oh
yeah yeah oh okay so but I would look at
the photos of her and her boyfriend
you're nasty oh I would just take it out
on him
you know but yeah she was like you're
like I can't believe it but I'll still
be a part of it hey why not I was
destructive young man you know what I
mean at that particular Junction I've
heard that about men that like some men
become dogs like yeah sleep with a lot
of women it's like they're red pilled
even if it's not like them simping for a
girl like it's them they get red pilled
because they sleep with so many girls
with boyfriends men and boyfriends have
no idea men become dogs because of women
yeah are bad are bad you mad the men
that you create [__] that's who they mad
at that's facts come on now like all of
us most men on the channel I would say
my audience would love to be blue pill
maybe purple pill would just love to be
rose-colored glasses but they take a
look at the family court injustices they
take a look at how laws are enacted
differently they see how in a criminal
they see all these different things the
stat they see the homelessness right
they they didn't have experiences and
they probably watch their father go
through it right like they've seen all
these things and they're just like wait
a minute is the juice really worth the
Modern Woman squeeze
and that's that was a pill that I that
was really hard for me to swallow when I
was listening to the content because
it's hard like as a girl to hear like
all this stuff like just talking about
all the problems with women right yeah
but the point I think is that men have
been listening to our problems with men
for years so I just think there's a
point where we should just listen and
learn
I think that this content not only
benefits the men that watch it but I
think it might benefit the women even
more it does it's helped me understand
men a lot better and even even with
non-dating relationships like my
brothers my dad like I just have
understood how they think a lot better
yeah and I didn't realize like you know
men view respect as love so if I if I'm
question like and also we don't realize
that men when you're constantly
questioning men like why are we doing it
this way like we might be doing it
because we want more information or
we're nosy or whatever but men view that
as like that's one as annoying as hell
yeah and it's not giving me peace and
but it's like it's just a difference in
communication style that sometimes I
don't think is intentional yeah but that
was something that helps me understand
you trigger me again yeah I've been in
dating relationships with women where
it's just like they won't consign they
won't be concise to a point I understand
women communicate in a lot more loftier
and but in my mind I'm just thinking
like Tom his money girl and you know it
is but they're they're not willing to
change their communication style to fit
how a man might like to communicate and
that is padded by the dogma of our
society today that just completely
panders to them and their emotions and
while still painting that men ain't
absurd it reminds me of something that
happened to me once go ahead personal
anecdotes let's get in there I was
thinking of how I when I one of my
ex-boyfriends was like I was telling him
a story yeah and he was just like shut
up I don't care
but I didn't realize I was like I've
probably been driving him crazy because
I've been telling him all these stories
that he does not this is when I was blue
pill yeah that he does not give a [__]
like he doesn't care what happened at
work he doesn't care what's going on we
don't give a [__] no we don't give a
[__] about your nail appointments we
don't give a [__] what happened at the
hairdresser we don't care Pearl sorry
but you know yeah yeah it's uh
interesting but but I did understand
like where he was coming from when I
started to listen to the content right
we want to solve problems we we wanna we
wanna we wanna fix [__] if you telling
me a story I'm thinking about my mind
well why don't you just stop talking to
him like what like why did you just like
like why why are we why is it so why why
is it so deep in the conversation like
right like you could you could have
stopped talking to sue Sue was obviously
a terrible human
who gives a [__] we leave her in the
dust you know what I'm saying that's how
my mind thinks all right but we're just
like trying to let it out because I I
think women we experience more like
negative emotion like in the I can't
remember what the scientific term is so
when we talk we just want to let it out
we're just like this is annoying
and then you'll be like oh well you talk
[__] about your friends or do you hate
like why do women they're so two-faced
whatever but I feel like there's just
part of like we just speak differently
yeah incredibly differently how to that
should be a show on the wife's school is
how to communicate with a man
you want to teach it
all right listen I could do a syllabus
like I can do a whole I could do a whole
curriculum looking you could you could
teach it and then after they could try
to communicate with you the bachelor
that that'll be the test right there we
got yeah after the whole Gambit the
cooking the cleaning the hoes would come
in and be like all right let's let's
start you want to communicate a problem
with him and then the girls will come up
and they'll be like you ain't [__]
we'll be like Rebecca Rebecca relax
first of all you need to that's not how
to do it all right Tracy you try
tell me yeah what's the best way for a
girl to communicate a problem to you
um that's an issue with you so here's
the thing is that I think women should
first preference the preface the
conversation okay is this a listening
conversation or is this a solution
conversation preface it nine times out
of ten if it's a listening conversation
I probably don't want to listen to it I
probably don't but that's what your
homegirls are for right that's what your
home girls are for right have the
homegirl conversations that's fine I'm
more than likely to not have something
else more important to do but see that's
when they call men not being like
emotional or this up because I don't
want to listen to your [__] okay
what if we have a problem with the way
that you treat like you you did
something that pissed her off what's the
best way for her to respectfully and
peacefully no so tell me give us give us
a step by step here's the thing number
one guys don't choose women that are not
coachable that's the first thing so it's
accountable up to the guy to First
choose a woman that you can have these
conversations with don't go off and look
at these goddamn Tick Tock shits of
these women being toxic as [__] and
saying oh no that's the kind of woman
that I want I want that toxic ass woman
as weird as that might sound Pearl our
culture today pushes toxicity in women
right so that's the first thing is to
identify the ones that are teachable in
nature so you have a teachable now now
what are you teaching her
um sometimes they have to be taught
um what is respectful to me okay how to
communicate with me so if we're gonna
have a solution conversation we can do
such in a way where
I've actually tried to do this before we
have stop watches
right so that she knows okay I got a
minute you got a minute we're gonna if
we gotta have some type of we have some
beef you know what I'm saying some
relationship beef so we can get down to
the poignant we can solve it listen at
the end of the day you know I worked at
Corporate America as I talked about
before if the consultants in culprit
America that were trying to solve these
issues didn't have concise bulleted well
thought out well researched points then
they would never come up to a solution
that would allow them to get invited
back to the table so we can pay them 500
000 a week to solve future problems I
think the the the idea of problem
solving is not something that is studied
enough between
um men and women in relationships in
modern society today
did I answer the question no okay what
so how so how does the woman bring the
problem to you let's say um
common what's a comment Donovan what's a
common issue that women have oh yeah so
maybe I don't I I don't like the way you
talk to me if she comes to me and she
says to me I don't like the way that you
talk to me yeah so you want me to come
back that or you want so I think maybe
let's say to genuine because sometimes I
know I know the guys are like oh you
know when like you just are trying to
communicate like a girl but maybe
sometimes like he
but see here's the thing right I don't
think that that's a respectful way to
address a man in a conversation I think
if it's something off the way that he
talks then say how is it what a man
would think that in a logical way say
Hey you communicated to me here
regarding this and based off of the
outcome of that it was incorrect because
of what had happened and then in his
mind he'd say oh okay the solution was
not what the particular problem was what
can I then go back to and communicate it
at a different way in a different level
more specific so you say like this is
what pissed me off if you just say I
don't like the way that you talk to me
right it's like what is he supposed to
do with that what is that again imagine
the consultant walks into the room and
says I don't like the way that you guys
talk to your employees what the [__] is
that right
what that's not a recommendation that's
not a solution-oriented approach
give me the research give me the
information give me what happened on
what day give me examples you know what
helped me when I started to ask myself
like what would make me happy okay so
like if I'm frustrated this is not even
with relation just with anything right
so if I have an employee that's pissing
me off or like this like because I'd ask
my dad I'm like Dad I just get so
frustrated with like certain business
problems or relation whatever it is
right yeah and I just have to keep
saying like what is the solution it's
really hard as a woman but I'm like what
is the solution what is the solution
like what would make you happy like what
Behavior like they need to do this like
that would make because a lot of times
like I think it's women we don't even
know yeah yeah we don't even know what
makes us happy
I think that we're you know we're all
tribal people I think women are a little
bit more susceptible to being um
included in a tribe and I I think
um there's evolutionary reasons
established with that whereas men might
be more competitive right uh women are a
little bit more um agreeable within that
and I think that
the inability to understand like what
you just described or like understand
like how things are pointed in position
to not give in to the man I think a lot
of it just goes back to what we're
exposed to what my what what women are
exposed to is it's so interesting to me
that modern women today complain about
men not being emotional but you often
what I find is that the Modern Woman
today has no empathy for the Modern Man
whatsoever I think um at least the ones
that um are not doing the things to
become of marriageable material there
are women out there and unless I got
emails I'm sure that you get emails all
day from women that say you know because
of your content I am now a better wife I
am now and I also get the ones that I am
now a better mother I am now a better
sister I'm now a better daughter and
understanding like my father because of
the content that's down into the space
but I think that while they're going to
be introduced to mainstream media they
have to come into our spaces and to see
okay
how is it that men really think what is
the what is the male experience
what is our points what is our positions
you know yeah because a lot of us have
never even heard it yeah and ever if men
don't even fully know how to articulate
it because they're they're a lot of the
younger guys are really feminized by the
media yes so it's like you have these
young guys saying oh I don't care what a
girl's body count when they know in
their like visceral reaction they do
yeah and they're they're just kind of
adapting to the women because you know
um
it's like it's like what do they say
under five is the new version
because it's modern yeah
but you know in the old days a girl
slept with three guys and that's Haram
now the men pray for it so on some level
the men are just kind of adapting to the
market I have another question for you
yeah what do you say to your detractors
that say
a woman in a man's space she's grifting
um well first of all I had to look up
the definition of grifting when I first
saw this and it basically means like a
fraud right yeah so um I mean I think
one criticism that they have that is
correct which is a woman will never
understand the men's struggle so a lot
of times when men I'm talking men like
think that I understand their struggle
in the way that they do I will never
understand the man's struggle I've never
been a man I will never understand it in
the way that men do
um the second part is I'm not selling
anything
um so it's like just entertainment yeah
it's like
inside yeah but I never want to
like I did all the research that the men
have done for 10 years right there's
guys that have done 10 20 years of
research in the space right I never want
to take credit for their work that's why
I say entertainment right because I just
don't I don't want to be disrespectful
to the men that have been here for so
long right but so I try to just explain
things the way the men see it and
sometimes women find it a little bit
more palatable so I mean they can call
me a grifter I'm basically saying I
don't believe what I say anyone that
knows me personally knows I believe what
I say sometimes it changes sometimes I'm
wrong and like the third thing is some
of y'all coming at me for grifting
endorsed channels that have a thousand
dollar courses I have no problem with
that I want to say I have no problem
with anyone making money I think go
ahead if you've done the work do it but
if you're gonna come at me for grifting
I hope you have the same you have the
same energy for the people with these
courses and they never do
I'm just saying I don't sell anything
but I am probably gonna put out a
YouTube course so Hey listen I I think
um it's a capitalistic Society if you've
got something to offer on to the market
you should I don't know if the
necessarily if the if the grifting is
specific to selling things so much as a
woman in a man's space but I like what
you said in terms of not first of all
saying respect to the people that have
done it before you but then also I've
heard you say in the Hafiz conversation
that you don't give advice you provide
entertainment and I think that that's a
distinction that when I heard at first I
thought is that a cop-out Pearl but then
I was thinking well if that's the
prescription of what it is that you
provide on to the market then
entertainment is also why the views went
through the roof
talk about the female point of view oh
there's so many it's most of them and
then they'll talk about life school but
wife school isn't me giving advice I
might I'm not gonna say I'll never give
advice ever in the future I'm I'm not
I'm not gonna say that but I'm saying
like one I think I think men should
advise other men in general I'm with you
I think that's just better and like for
the women like I just think I'd rather
be married before I give advice that's
just my personal opinion on it but
um you mean before you mean for wife
school to give advice yeah like it's
we're bringing in wives or other people
to come in and give advice it's not me
giving the advice but then they don't
even watch wife school and then they
yeah that's like me trying to talk to a
married couple regarding their
relationship yeah you know what I'm
saying like if a dude wants to contact
me you know for consultation or
something which I don't do right now by
the way because stressful but if they
want a concert I could I could talk
about relationship stuff but at the
point of marriage
I you know I that's best outside of my
wheelhouse yeah well
it's one of them yeah but I also like
what you said too in terms of you know
it's not your place to tell men what to
do and the first thing that I thought
about is that um you know women do not
have the uh equipment so to speak uh to
make a boy into a man no oh no you know
it's just the way that I am the way that
I carry myself the way to be an
illustrative example of manhood for a
young boy is just something that a
single mother cannot do but we get so
disrespected in modern times today that
single mothers will go up on Father's
Day less so now because the content
that's in the space but we'll go up on
Father's Day and say I'm the best father
that is that in the third and I think
it's just so disrespectful when there's
so much data on two-parent household
with so much information on the benefits
of having the father in the household
and you know I think about the influence
that my father has had on my life and I
my father is maybe I'm biased I think
he's the best father in the world and I
don't know what my life would be like or
you know being able to respond to
different things versus react to
different situations unless I watched my
father in those situations as a boy
watching a man conduct himself in that
particular order if I never saw my
father work as hard as he did and he
gave up components of his lifestyle and
his future he's he's in the music he was
on tour with like I'll be sure and [__]
like that back into the day you know you
may not know who I'll be sure is but
okay yeah he's he's good yeah but he was
on tour with him back in the day and
everything like that and put all of that
on hold to make sure that he could be an
influence uh within my life and the
thing is if I didn't have that structure
I would not have been as successful as I
am today
um I would have not I probably would
have had multiple babies by now you know
because after discipline then this gets
energy
you know what I'm saying I probably
would have been with a with a with an
unsavory chick you know what I'm saying
uh and all these different things so I
think it's just it's so quintessential
that we continue to prop up the
importance of masculinity the importance
of manhood The Importance of Being a
strong
man in society today and I really truly
believe that so although you may not
give advice I do give advice to these
men as well because I think that it's I
think at the end of the day if you
create a society of fantastically strong
men the women will get in line they have
no choice
oh yeah we love getting in line for
strong mind like come on ladies you're
so fast
BDSM book the uh you know what I'm
talking about 50. 50 Shades that's why
it was so popular because they they boss
bees out in public but they get behind
closed doors and they want to just be
is that right oh it's getting weird now
is this getting weird I won't stare at
you directly I look at the camera when
I'm talking like this Pearl are you
blushing
my bad Mr Pearl no disrespect my young
scholar
I mean no disrespect okay yeah
I heard that that film was equally
um
popular among Church Like Girls Too come
on so the church like they're like oh
the the women are better in the church
not particularly have you ever told you
my thing about the church making hoes
talk about it I have a a a theory that
I've kind of developed yeah that the
church is a homemaker
Homemaker yeah the church makes hoes I
can't imagine come on so we have the
pastor what is the pastor famous for
screw in the congregation right right
right that's a stereotype I'm not saying
all and everyone's like what churches
have you gone to well it's a stereotype
it's something that does happen okay and
it's common enough that I can say it's a
stereotype I thought you're gonna say
something else so we're not talking
about Catholic Church no no but that's
somewhat and that's not funny yeah
that's a different but anyway so so what
they do is they have so that remember
the Chastity speakers I was telling you
about yeah so they have this message
that you can be a born-again hoe so like
what you can sleep around and find a
husband so now why are they saying that
well because the pastor screw in the
congregation and he's thinking I gotta
do something with these hoes once I'm
done so betas come on in and so then and
so then the women the hoes they're like
attracted to that like this sounds
amazing I can just say I'm sorry for
screwing Tyrone and Chad for 20 years
and now there's a husband whistle
they're like sign me up I'm getting in
this church and then and then so it's
like kind of like the pastor is screwing
the congregation and preaching
forgiveness to the betas and he's like
yeah you deal with these hoes because
I'm not going to
and then and then
um they they Market hodem because they
Market you can be a born-again virgin
make the guy wait get the nice husband
get it all and that's why the church has
worse women than in the general
population and that's why the church
also has so many hosts and that's why
the men say the churches has worse girls
interesting that's why so so essentially
the pastor is the Pandora
yeah because he's the one screwing the
congregation and then he creates a whole
bunch of betas he creates the house
right but then baiters from the guys to
Priestess forgiveness and then also
probably much more Alpha Tendencies with
the women because you know what I'm
saying he's the head guy so why would he
want strong men in the congregation
and and
on top of that like no masculine man
masculine men come to church and they're
like what is this [__]
you want me to wait you want me to not
blow her back out when the last 20 guys
did I have you're gonna tell a man with
like high testosterone like oh yeah
absolutely let me wait six to nine
months because they all get married fast
you know in the church to get to know
her wait it out the masculine men are
like yeah the club's down the street
this is basically a club so let me go to
the actual class never in the history of
not ever have women in general and in
Mass appreciated the slow tired well let
me just say the Modern Woman have
appreciated the slow soft simple Strokes
of a modern man today it seems as though
they just breed it straight out of
listen give me the what's it called the
Grays what's it called the the book The
BD assemble Fifty Shades let me you see
I don't look at any of this stuff let me
get the 50 Shades of Gray treatment like
two degrees now I never read the book
but I have an idea of what it's about
that's what I'm saying though I feel
like the church is the Homemakers and
that's why there's more hoes in the
church hey
so so I should not go to should we go
grab oh we should go grab some church
girls for the batch for the back for the
MTR Bachelor can we can we go grab some
church girls it does depend on the
church I will say the only real virgins
that I do believe were virgins I've met
well
you know what never mind she's firing
clips
oh Pearl I'm just I will say I do think
there are good girls in the church but
that the pastor does after the
congregation y'all be on some Demon time
I don't know what y'all doing
and then it's even worse when like
they're married
Jesus and it always comes out like I
don't want to name any names but there's
some of these guys name them oh God
there's that one guy that came up for
Kevin
Jamal something okay I might be I don't
want to say a name and then not be the
person okay but there was one of these
guys that came out for Kevin and then it
was discovered later that this guy was
doing all types of stuff within the
congregation I don't know I don't follow
up on religion religious news but they
you know it's crazy they exist yeah but
you know at the same time is it are we
blowing out the number
uh because of what comes out in the
media like I really wonder maybe that
should be part of the the content we go
we go to like several churches no we get
like PhD researchers we go into several
churches now we start asking all of
these damn questions and then we get off
of that sample size we derive the total
populations of hoes created in church
versus the the the the the control
population of those in the in the
wilderness the girls you date won't tell
you their body count but you want to get
it from strangers in the church no no to
be honest well we'll give them tick
tocks because apparently modern women
today are the most honest all right just
just give them the tick tock the truth
will just come out there addicted to
validation I just think there's
stereotypes for a reason like why why is
there I went to Catholic school right
like why why do we hear that the
Catholic school girls are worse like
there's something to it there's
something like and a lot of times the
church people want to get up in arms and
be like well what churches do you go to
not all churches but I'm just like okay
let's let's take a step back why are the
men saying this it's not like the men
the men want pure young women the men
want it they don't they don't have any
incentive to call us hoes like they they
want good wives if you repress a modern
woman and then outside of that uh uh
repression is the media that tells her I
don't cook and I don't clean she's gonna
want to bust out can that be to a degree
of what's happening in this unique
example of the church you repress him to
the degree and maybe they have a Shifty
Shady leader but they're also exposed to
what's happening at large they're also
exposed to the overwhelming large
majority of feminized men that also grew
up in the same society and then they
just letting their ish loose I think
you're right
I think you're right we gotta fix it
Pearl we gotta we gotta we gotta Come
Together Like The Avengers
we gotta okay if we're gonna fix the
church we need we need equality in the
church not even equality like we needed
to go back we didn't the women need to
give up power to the men that's just my
opinion and this is you know I'm not the
the biggest church goer so maybe like
people can come I I have a more
experience than most young women in
church but I'm not die hard right but it
has to also be an auditing of those at
the head of the church because if you
give up the power you're still going to
have the con the head that's going to
want to bang them I'm saying like why do
we have like predictions we talk about
that but we don't talk about women with
social media addictions like why why is
that like it's always one-sided the men
need to be more the men need to do more
the men need to wait you know what that
might be is because there's a whole
pharmaceutical industry that benefits
off of women being adult addicted to
social media
follow the money
I'm getting red pilled a little further
Hey listen follow the money my in my
version I have a human nature version
you know some people who say female
nature my version and I say this because
it's not like a um like a book of this
is red pill here are the rules here's
this here's the you know what I'm saying
my version of it is going to be
um Human Nature and then also follow the
money
following the money will often get you
many answers in a capitalistic Society
follow the money
but that's a problem young women today
are the most medicated than they've ever
been in the history of ever oh my gosh
they die oh look at I'm not gonna say
anything they diagnose you with
everything I'm so tired of these
diagnosis tired of it go exercise how
about that I'm tired of I'm tired of
trauma trauma I'm tired of hearing about
these hoes trauma
give me an example of some hose trauma
like I like like ground meat
about
were that's real trauma
get back into go around say I have
trauma now fix your [__] oh my God go to
a therapist fix it we are done let's
shout out auntie we are done listening
to these hoes talk about trauma we're
done with your [__] it's so done it's
just like if you have trauma fix it
we're sick of hearing about it they
don't fix it I'm tired of healing they
don't fix it
down by Tyrone like shut up they don't
fix it till they hit their Brittany
Renner stride
I do think like if you take away
consequences people will push it I do
think this is true about men and women
right so if you couldn't get if you
could eat whatever you want you wouldn't
get fat you probably eat worse
no if I could eat whatever I want I'm
not going to get fat wait am I miss you
if you could eat whatever you want and
not get fat would you eat worse like
would you eat more junk food if I could
eat whatever I want and not get fat I
would still think about cardiovascular
issues none of the health effects I get
real logical with these questions okay
and not have the health effects so not
get fat and not the health effects and I
could just eat and eat right and there
wouldn't be no content so when you take
away the consequences from people they
act worse it's like basic
it's it's basic so with women like we
don't have consequence because honestly
y'all simps bail us out
like you they do so not only is the
content in the space trying to help
women understand men more but it's also
trying to get all of the weak men the
pacified just just chilling on the couch
man that will just flick through
Instagram for hours RN or just flick
through Tinder through hours on end it's
also trying to get them
to man the [__] up they're killing
they're killing the goddamn uh economics
of the dating Marketplace could these
women they'll get all of these goddamn
likes and think that they can that then
translates and then them being
marriageable material or they'll get the
vying eye of attention of someone that
works for some type of athletic
organization and think that oh I could
probably marry a guy on that same damn
level as well I don't know why anyone in
their right mind would they they're not
in their right mind yeah shout out to
day one in a way though when you think
about it it's like in a way Rolo talks a
lot about this how like everyone's
feminist and today because we've all
been influenced by it I can see that and
I I honestly I was thinking about it I'm
like he's kind of right
because even me like having having a
podcast like that's feminism in a way
can we also Define what we mean we talk
about feminism like just in case because
this is probably clipped up I'm not
talking about
oh oh this is actually something that
I'm not talking about like equal rights
right I'm talking about the versions of
feminism that paint men as complete dogs
and [__] men ain't [__] right while
also um putting up women up on a
pedestal it's like a superiority version
of feminism I don't like the components
of feminism that say uh you could be
born a man in transition into a woman
and then compete in athletic sports I I
like the illogical versions of uh
feminism what is that done I don't like
the versions of it where it's sexually
liberated with no consequences the [__]
walks a hashtag [__] world can we talk
about the [__] come on let's talk about
it Pearl why
why like why did they have my boy 21
Savage up there that's sad I'm a [__]
too the nerve of you that's that's how
when you got gangster rappers he's from
londontown too I think but when you have
gangster rappers that are goddamn
putting up I am a [__] because of his
girlfriend is is pressing that that
that's that's what you got to say what
is happening [__] are we saying it and
it's well it's pandering because the
same guys that say they don't care about
body count let's say they don't care
about [__] like they'll come on the
show
I
know these men are not wifing these
girls they're just trying to get laid
and so it's like you're telling the
girls what they want to hear so what but
it's like you're just trying to screw up
they're gonna get the pity viscous
inerts potentially but but not not the
masculine viscous centers that that we
are owed you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah don't go deep on that one yet leave
that over to me leave that over to me
hahaha
all right we got anything else I feel
like I've covered most everything I
wanted to cover yeah I have some
questions right now but I think we've
gone over so many different things yeah
I'll try to be more structured next time
no promises though Pearl you keep doing
what has ever made you
where you are right now
I'll keep you structured though if you
do if you're doing it with me whatever
you're doing is working bro so keep on
doing your thing and the people love you
because of it well thank you for coming
on
I appreciate your time I appreciate it I
had such a good time here today one
thing I want to let the folks know as
well is we might have touched on this a
little bit but you work so damn hard you
know when I came into the game too I
feel like a lot of people were talking
about how hard you know videos every day
I feel like it's more normal now within
that
um but you work an incredibly hard
amount so I think that you deserve kudos
for that as well I think a lot of people
that end up inevitably complaining about
your position are not ready willing and
able to put the same amount of work in
that you have so shout out to you thank
you I appreciate that hurray
I actually you do you do teaspoon not
content oh gosh Castle say something
real quick as well is that um I think
it's interesting for my we haven't
gotten into content we're going to talk
about content in the space as well I
think it's interesting
uh how fast that the space has changed
over time I was one of the first and I
received so much Flack for it for
inviting women to sit right next to me
and have these conversations right to
look at an AMS video or stuff is cold
video a dating video and have women sit
right next to me my first video up on
the channel
may not be my first one
I don't know maybe might be my first
public win my first public dating one
was an AMS reaction and I had a lovely
young lady sitting right next to me and
um
we just had a conversation regarding the
amount of comments that I had down in
there that would say something like you
know you can't take a fit you can't
teach a fish how to be a fisherman or
something like that the amount of
comments that I had the amount of
negativity that I have but I saw
something in there outside of everyone
giving me all of this BS all of this
Flack for bringing women out into the
space to react off of these things uh
and I just kept on going forward with it
I had to switch a little bit to a degree
back when it happened because then I
couldn't that I had to switch up how I
did my content and I'm like God what do
I do
um so not only being you know changing
up components of the space to allow for
women to at least hear it which I say is
more normal place now like you know
we've had Kevin Samuels you now have
fresh and fit and now we have women that
have platforms within the general you
know occupying the space as well
um but then also transitioning it to the
reactions that are focused straight on
the dating and the relationships
being at the Forefront of that and
seeing how fast that it has changed
is is so crazy and it just reminds me to
always stay flexible
um don't stay in your comfort zone uh
ensure that you are being uncomfortable
with your degree of comfortability and
even now like you know what I said in
2023 is I'm gonna start doing a lot more
collaborations so when we were
communicating I was happy for this one
to be one of my very first ones so so
thank you Pro
thank you for coming appreciate it let
the let the people know where they can
find you
my name is mediocre tourism reviews much
more affectionately known as MTR you can
find me on Instagram at the real MTR I
have a patreon feel free to support up
there connected to my patreon is my
Discord server where you can engage in
conversation with me as well as some of
the people in my inner sanctum we do
live streams I'm starting to start up
the red cup talks yet again if you want
to live streams I consider you a part of
the empty Army you like that play on
words like that yeah I've been thinking
about stuff like that uh modern man's
playbook.com I talked about a little bit
earlier in the Stream but guys if you're
interested in understanding
um what success should look like for men
and then also specifically on how to be
successful as a modern man in modern
society today dealing with modern woman
I mean [__] the whole first module is
how to identify toxicity in women
identify it identify identify identify
because if you don't
then you're going to get the
repercussions of that on the other side
I think that's all I want to shout out
for right now cool cool guys go
subscribe to this chat for real I love
watching your reaction videos I think
they're great so go subscribe to his
channel like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel also sign up
for my membership tiers if you want to
know how I blew up on YouTube fourth
membership tier or if we're gonna have a
course coming out probably in the next
six months
um let me know anything else um if you
guys want to be content for mtr's love
yeah
send me the DM we're gonna put it
together what's your IG oh it's just
pearly things one they took away my
other one I was trying to look for you
the other day and I couldn't find you
okay so I didn't know it's just probably
things one so go go follow that because
they took away my other one sad oh
they're haters it was all I called one
girl after she called me ugly after she
called she called me ugly I called her
back she started it they take away my
account it's like the the Nerf yeah
anyways go follow that subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time peace